Ellen.
Yes, Miss Fiske.
- Is there any mail for me?
No, just this one letter.
No sign of Bates yet?
- Not yet.
Oh dear, I do hope you
won't miss your train.
I mustn't.
Oh Lucy, hurry with that bag.
- Just coming, Miss.
Ellen.
That business I want you
to see about in London.
This is for Mr Scott at the bank.
It's about those Brazilian
bonds of mine.
The way the market is this week,
I think they ought to be ..
Get outside.
Keep your eyes open for Bates.
Yes, Miss.
And this address is
just off Berkeley Square.
Go to the servant's entrance and
ask for Mr Blake. He's the butler.
Say you've come from me with
a message for Lord Cardington.
And will he give it to his
Lordship .. privately.
Ellen, you aren't paying attention.
But I am, Miss Fiske.
What would be the best time to call?
Harry always used to dine around eight.
You call about half past seven.
- Yes, very well.
You seem upset.
Bad news?
I don't want to bother
you with my troubles.
It isn't a question of bothering
me with your troubles.
You've become almost like my daughter.
The letter is from my sisters,
Emily and Louisa.
They're very unhappy back
in London without me.
After all, I only saw them once since
I came to work for you, Miss Fiske.
You'll see them today, won't you?
And everything will be alright, surely.
Miss Fiske.
Bates is coming.
Tell him to hurry himself.
My kind regards to your sisters, Ellen.
- Thank you, Miss Fiske.
I've written them so much about you.
How kind you've been.
Stuff and nonsense.
I'm fond of you. You shouldn't ..
Oh, a lovely juicy one.
Perhaps you'll .. you might allow
them down for a little visit one day?
Oh dear, look what the damp has done.
Certainly, yes.
By all means. At any time.
You know Lucy polished this
table all yesterday afternoon.
Miss Fiske.
- Yes?
It occurred to me that ..
Since they've been so wretched lately,
and you may allow them to visit one day.
Oh that? Yes, indeed. You tell them.
Perhaps in the spring when
it's warm and sunny.
Well .. what I was going to ask was ..
Might I bring them back
with me this time? Now?
Well now, Ellen.
- They won't be a bother.
I promise Miss Fiske .. and it
will mean so much to them.
Very well my dear. You bring with
you by all means. For a day or two.
Thank you, Miss Fiske.
I can't tell you how grateful I am.
- Well don't try, my dear.
He's here, Miss.
- About time. The good-for-nothing.
Ellen, have you got everything?
- Yes, Miss Fiske.
Morning, ma'am.
Bates, you might have been more prompt.
What on earth made you so late?
Her. You can't gallop over the roads
with a lady in her delicate condition.
She's going to throw a calf, she be.
I'm taking her to the vets, I am.
Kindly let her not throw any calves
until you get Miss Ellen to the station.
Calves don't come by timetable, lady.
- Well trains do.
Yes, ma'am.
- Goodbye, Miss Fiske.
Goodbye, Miss Ellen.
- Goodbye, Lucy.
Don't forget the allowance
from you-know-who.
No, I shan't.
Goodbye.
Lucy.
- Yes, Miss.
Alright now, there is a
day's work to be done.
La, la, la .. la, la, la.
This is nice. It's very, very nice.
- What's that you have there, Miss?
It's called the New Comic Opera.
It's all the rage in London.
The Mi-Ka-Do.
Mikado.
I used to tour the provinces with
the gentleman who sent it to me.
Look, he signed it for me:
'Rutland Barington'.
'For my adored Leonora
with fond memories of ..'
Never mind about that.
Go and do the dishes.
Yes, Miss.
On a tree by a willow, a little tom-tit.
Sang: willow, tit-willow, tit-willow.
And I said to him: dicky-bird,
why do you sit?
Singing: willow, tit-willow, tit-willow.
Go on. Don't stop.
Who are you? What are you doing here?
- Listening .. very nice too.
What do you want?
- Ask me in and I'll tell you.
Anyway young man, you may
come in .. but mind your manners.
Alright, Miss.
Isn't this where Miss Ellen Creed lives?
- Yes, she lives here.
What do you wish to see her about?
- It's a personal matter.
She's my aunt. I'm Albert Feather.
Your aunt?
- Right.
Her mother was my stepfather's
uncle's second wife.
And where do you come from?
- Gravesend.
I .. I work in a bank there.
It's a very long walk.
Hadn't you better sit down?
Thank you.
I'm afraid it's all been for nothing.
Your aunt Ellen has gone to
London on some business for me.
How long will she be away?
A few days.
- A few?
Blimey. That will be too late.
Is there anything I can do?
I'm Miss Fiske. Your aunt has been
working here as a housekeeper/companion.
I didn't know.
I haven't seen her for five years.
Can I help?
I wonder.
What's the trouble?
Or is it trouble?
It's trouble right enough.
I hardly like to tell you.
Oh, I see.
What's the amount?
Twelve pounds.
- How much?
- My goodness. That's a lot of money.
I know. What's worse,
I must have it by tonight.
I'm short at the bank.
It means jail if I can't put it back
before the cashier checks up.
Gambling?
- No. A girl.
Are you engaged to her?
No. She's an actress.
She was in a travelling
company in Gravesend.
What? At the Old Grand?
You know it?
- I played there.
Years ago.
You were an actress?
Front row of the chorus.
Fourth from the right.
She was in the chorus too.
I expect you took her out to supper.
Then she persuaded you to
go round the shops with her.
How did you know?
'Imagination', my boy.
Anyway, she's over the hills
now to some other town.
And with some other fool.
The little cheat.
Don't worry any more about it.
I'll give you the twelve pounds.
You will?
Perhaps I owe it to you .. in a sense.
Or to some other fool.
You're a life-saver.
Now you just wait here. I'll just
run upstairs and get my keys.
A pity there aren't more like you.
That my, lad, is a matter of opinion.
Do you mind if I tickle on your ivories?
- No, do.
Thank you.
It's the same the whole world over.
It's ..
It's the poor what gets the blame.
While the rich has all the pleasures.
Now, ain't that the blinking shame.
Hello.
You did scare me.
I thought I was hearing things.
You were.
But I mean.
A man's voice.
So funny here.
Doesn't the tide wash up
many male fish, my angel?
A man is as scarce as
hansom cabs in these parts.
That is, all but the old ones.
The young ones go off to London or
some foreign parts as soon as they can.
Are you going off to foreign parts?
It depends.
- Depends on what?
If anyone ever asks me.
I shouldn't think with eyes like them
there would be any difficulty.
Go on.
What's your name?
- Lucy.
What's yours?
- Albert. I'm Miss Creel's nephew.
Funny .. I never heard about you.
That must be remedied.
How about making the most of a male
fish now one has been washed up, eh?
What about a smacker?
- No, you mustn't.
I don't know you.
You needn't know people to kiss them.
- I do.
Alright my girl. It's your loss.
You think a lot of yourself, don't you?
Has Lucy been entertaining you, Albert?
- Eh?
She came in. We had a word or two.
Nice looker, isn't she?
- I didn't notice.
Come now, Albert.
Don't lose your sense of humour.
I hope you're not one of those who
won't benefit from experience.
Otherwise my twelve pounds
will be rather wasted, won't it.
Don't you worry Miss Fiske.
I've had my lesson.
I hope so.
Now .. this is where we
keep our little hoard.
It's an old bake-oven really.
A proper tomb, isn't it?
What's that?
This is what they used to
pull the loaves out with.
Of course, we don't use it as a
bake-oven. Hasn't been used in years.
Now then.
Twelve pounds, I think you said.
You couldn't make if fifteen?
- No, I couldn't.
You couldn't?
Do I give you an I.O.U.?
No thank you.
This isn't a loan.
I shouldn't like you to incur the
remorse of not paying it back.
You are a daisy.
Very prettily done, Albert.
Now, let's forget all about it.
If you came next week, you'd have
found three of your aunts here.
Ellen is bringing her
sisters back from London.
What, the potty ones?
- Potty?
Queer as mice in a cage.
They're quite harmless.
Especially when aunt Ellen's around.
For comfort, they're coming
to stay here for a few days.
They seem to mean quite a
great deal to your aunt Ellen.
Oh, they would.
She's looked after them
since she was a kid.
She's watched over them like they were
a couple of perishing babes-in-arms.
I think that's very commendable of her.
- Perhaps, but ..
Think of all the fun she's missing.
What, for example?
- You know.
I see.
I have to be toddling along.
I'll pay you back as soon as I can.
I'd appreciate if you don't mention
our little transaction to aunt Ellen.
Very well. If you like.
How about .. whatsername?
Lucy? Oh she won't say anything.
I'll take care of that.
Thanks.
So long my lady.
And again from the heart. I'll never
forget your kindness as long as I live.
I hope you live a great
deal longer than that.
Isn't it funny, Ellen? You can't see
the wind and you can't touch it.
But it's there.
I think you'd better have this round
you, dear. It's getting quite chilly.
Listen .. what's that?
Those are The Priory bells, dear.
From over the marshes.
Oh .. I shan't like that.
She hates bells.
- Especially church bells.
Ding dong, ding dong, ding dong.
Aren't the marshes pretty.
The grass is too long and untidy.
If I had a knife and a bit of string,
I'd cut it and tie it up in bundles.
Are there any sheep here on the marshes?
- Yes, Miss.
I think sheep are so clever to
chew their cud the way they do.
It's very difficult.
I've tried.
You ought to be a sailor, Miss.
They're always chewing tobacco.
The man I was to marry was a sailor.
He gave me this.
It's all I have to remember him by.
He was wrecked at sea.
They were all drowned.
It must have been a bit of
sadness for you, Missy.
Oh no. I've quite forgotten
what he looked like.
I saw a drowned man once. They took
him out of the Thames. He was green.
Frogs.
There must be lots of frogs.
We used to have such
fun with them at home.
We used to put them on the dining-table
and make them jump in the marmalade pot.
Look. There's a bird's nest.
- So there is.
It must be last summer's.
- I should like to have that.
Bates, stop please.
Oh .. I have it.
Isn't it beautiful?
- Oh dear, it's all cobwebby.
And it has a horrid smell.
- It mustn't be wasted.
I shall save it until next year
and then I'll put it back again.
Who knows where we'll be next year?
Not in London anyway. You promised that.
Yes, I promised that.
- Look.
Louisa .. how did that happen?
She did it.
- Who?
That woman in London.
She didn't give us enough food either.
- 'Discipline' she said.
Louisa used to cry all night.
I didn't. She couldn't discipline me.
We'll be alright here
though with Miss Fiske.
She won't beat us.
No darling, she won't beat you.
No-one will again. Ever.
Now remember what I told you both.
You're not to talk too much.
Wait until Miss Fiske knows you better.
How can she get to know
us better if we don't talk?
Come along dear.
Bates, get the luggage, will you.
Yes, ma'am.
They look harmless.
- What, Miss?
Never mind. Go and put the kettle on.
- Yes, Miss.
Well, here we are.
- I'm glad.
Miss Fiske .. my sister
Emily, my sister Louisa.
How do you do, Emily?
- We're very glad to be here.
Louisa.
- I don't like people to touch me.
I'm afraid Miss Fiske will
think you're very rude.
They're rather tired, poor dears.
- I never get tired.
I sometimes walk about
the house all night.
Do you indeed?
- No, of course she doesn't, Miss Fiske.
What beautiful furniture.
Just like we used to have
before we lost all our money.
Some of these are our things, dear.
Miss Fiske bought them at my Curio Shop.
I want my tea.
Emily, see .. here's the
grand champ himself.
Remember when father bought him for us?
I wonder if his head still nods.
Ding-dong, ding-dong ..
- Louisa, dear.
Bates, be careful.
You'll scratch the furniture.
Very good, ma'am.
I must say you've brought
enough luggage with you.
We've brought everything.
- Everything?
We had to.
- Why?
When they sent for the police.
Now, my dears. I'm sure all this
can't possibly interest Miss Fiske.
I think we should go up
and rest a bit before tea.
Whatever you say, Ellen.
- Come along, Emily.
That smelly train was very dirty.
She's always fussing about the dirt.
I hope you keep things tidy here.
Cleanliness is next to
Godliness .. don't you agree?
Well .. I'm quite clean, I believe.
But I don't know that
I'm particularly Godly.
I thought you were a Roman.
Isn't that yours?
Miss Fiske is a Roman, dear.
And a very devoted one.
Come along Louisa, Emily.
Father, didn't approve of Romans.
And neither do I.
I expect it's one of those boobies.
Miss Emily was drawing cat's faces on
brown paper yesterday when you were out.
I can't stand it. I can't stand it.
My lovely paisley shawl. It's ruined.
You'd better get some vinegar and see
if you can do something about this spot.
Yes, Miss.
I'm utterly exhausted clearing
up after their messes.
I don't wonder, Miss. So am I.
And you should see their
bedroom. It's like a goat's-pen.
I know it. If it isn't one
thing, it's another.
For the last six weeks were like living
in the middle of Piccadilly Circus.
My heart won't stand it.
Go and get my smelling salts.
Where are they, Miss?
- In the usual place, of course.
Nothing is in the usual
place these days.
No.
Well then, get me a cold compress.
I shall lie down and
take a nap while I can.
Miss Fiske.
Yes, what is it? What is it?
- Will they be staying much longer?
They'll have my invitation
to go this evening.
Oh dear, I wonder where Emily has
gone to. She ought to be back by now.
I can't see her anywhere.
I wish I were brave like Emily.
I should like to take long walks too.
And pick up things.
Perhaps I shall be able to
after we've stayed here longer.
I'm sure you will, dear.
I shall be staying here, shan't I?
You're not planning to send us away?
Are you, Ellen?
No dear. Of course I'm not.
This is what you've always promised us.
A little place in the country
where we can always be safe.
Yes .. it's the one thing
I've been working for.
Ever since we had to
give up the old house.
Naturally, Estuary House
could never be like that.
But it's nice enough.
Yes, and Miss Fiske has
been very kind to us.
Miss Fiske .. may I tell
you something, Ellen?
Just one of my secrets.
Of course you may.
I don't like Miss Fiske.
Couldn't we send her away? Then it
would really be just the three of us.
But I keep telling you,
Louisa. It's her house.
Oh no. You'll never
make me believe that.
All out lovely things are there.
We'll never have to go away, will we?
- No, darling. I promised you.
Never.
I think Miss Fiske wants us to go.
Both of us.
I'm sure I can persuade
her to let you stay.
Oh dear, I do wish Emily would come.
Maybe we'd better get along
home in case she's waiting there.
Come along, dear.
I don't want her upsetting Miss Fiske
again. She can be very tactless.
Here girl, take this.
Thanks a lot. What are we to do with it?
Put it in the woodshed,
where it belongs.
The woodshed is full. I won't have
you cluttering up my kitchen with it.
Very well then.
Oh dear ..
What is it now?
Wait until Miss Fiske sees this.
What's the matter now? My goodness.
More wood?
- Yes. Miss Emily dumped it.
Never mind. You get out of here.
- I got a nice lot today.
What are you thinking of? Making a
mess with it all over my clean floor.
The girl wouldn't let
me put it in the kitchen.
She's quite right. I told you to stop
bringing in wood. We have enough.
I must tidy up the river
banks. I hate waste.
And I hate litter. Now you
clear it away immediately.
I won't be ordered to do things.
This is too much.
My best polished table.
Look how these shells have scratched it.
What's this? Wet seaweed and a horrid ..
Dead bird.
Leave my bird alone. And my shells.
They are my treasures.
We don't understand expensive things.
It's so long since we had any.
I know it's very simple of me.
But I am simple.
Emily .. what's wrong?
I hate her. She threw my
bird into the fireplace.
Emily, control yourself.
See what she's done
with her ridiculous shells.
It will take a month's
polishing to put it right.
I'm sorry Miss Fiske, I'll put it right.
No Ellen, you shan't. I'll do it.
Let me do it. I'll polish it.
Every day, all through the winter.
Sweet of you, Louisa. But I doubt
you'll be here through the winter.
But we shall. Ellen said so.
You're mistaken, Louisa.
I said nothing of the kind.
But you did. You promised.
- Louisa, will you be quiet.
My heavens. This is the last straw.
You'll drive me as crazy as yourselves.
Oh, Ellen.
Miss Fiske.
I'm sorry. I didn't mean
to say that, but ..
I've had about as much as I can endure.
Emily .. take Louisa upstairs.
Now, stop your crying, Louisa.
There's nothing to cry about.
Do you hear?
Go upstairs. Both of you.
And close the door behind you.
That was a cruel thing to say.
But it's true.
One with her telescope and the other
with her mania for collecting things.
They are insane, both of them.
Please don't use that word again.
Emily was right.
But then people who
have all they want ..
Never understand how much the smallest
things mean to those who haven't.
Really?
I don't think this calls for a sermon.
I've been more than generous
to you and your sisters.
People have always been very
generous to you, Miss Fiske.
My sisters and I have never had
friends to send us money.
That's hardly my fault, is it.
- No.
Don't you feel you have a responsibility
to those less fortunate than you?
I don't know what you're talking about.
Life hasn't been very
kind to us, Miss Fiske.
Every penny we've ever
had, I've had to work for.
Every penny. But at least
we have our self-respect.
How dare you.
How dare you criticise my life.
Do you think I don't envy women who
have respectability? Who have families?
Who aren't just forgotten and pensioned
off when they lose their stock-in-trade.
Then you can't blame me
for fighting for my family.
Very admirable, but it's
your family and not mine.
Let me tell you this.
Your sisters, insane or not,
have overstayed their welcome.
I invite them here for two days
and they've stayed six weeks.
Or perhaps you were planning
to keep them here forever?
Well .. I had thought ..
That I might pay something out
of my wages for their keep.
Ellen, you're a hypocrite.
You're worse, you're a cheat.
You meant to foist your wretched
brood on me and bleed me white.
And when I saw through your scheme, you
had the insolence to turn and abuse me.
But you've chosen the wrong woman.
You get those sisters of yours
out of this house at once.
And take a month's wages
and go with them.
Miss Fiske.
Ellen .. why aren't you in bed?
Why are you prowling about at this hour?
Miss Fiske, may I come in?
I must talk with you, please.
Well, mind your tongue.
We don't want any more of
this afternoon's unpleasantness.
I'm sorry about that.
I was wrong. I shouldn't
have spoken to you as I did.
No .. you shouldn't.
Miss Fiske.
Do you remember the letter that arrived
the day I went away to London?
Yes .. what about it?
- It was from their landlady.
Emily and Louisa.
Had been a little difficult.
She'd sent for the police.
They were going to be
put away in an institution.
The landlady was quite right.
That's where they belong.
But Miss Fiske, you don't
understand. They're my sisters.
You don't know what I've
gone through for them.
They've no-one else in the
world to turn to but me.
I pleaded with the police to release
them. They agreed on one condition.
That they were to remain
in my personal care.
That I was to be responsible for them.
And if there were any more complaints.
That they were to be put away forever.
That's why I can't send them away.
All this devotion is
very admirable, Ellen.
But I fail to see how I can
help in any way at all.
Oh but you can. You can, Miss Fiske.
I thought perhaps they
might use the attic upstairs.
They'll stay there out of the
way where you don't see them.
They could use the back stairs
when they come in and out.
Ellen, what are you talking about?
I promise they'll never come near you.
You'll never know they're in the house.
I'll look after them myself.
I'll cook their meals for them.
I promise they won't
be any more trouble.
Miss Fiske, they must
be with me, they must.
I'll pay for their keep.
I'll work for nothing.
Please .. oh, please Miss Fiske.
Ellen, have you quite
gone out of your mind?
You must be blind if you can't realise
they'd always be getting in my way.
You pack them off tomorrow.
- But, Miss Fiske. Won't ..?
No Ellen, my mind is made up.
If you want to, you can stay here a few
days until you've found a new situation.
Now run along to bed. And make
certain they leave tomorrow.
You wouldn't want me to be sending
for the police, would you?
Goodnight Ellen. I'm tired.
Goodnight.
But you told her you were
going to send us away.
I'm not going to send you away.
We heard you. We were listening.
Isn't she terrible, Ellen?
She's wicked.
I'm not going to send you away.
Never.
If you're not sending us away,
what are you going to do?
I don't know.
I must think.
I've always wanted
to explore an old castle.
Will it have a dungeon do you think?
- They all have dungeons.
With bats.
No, dear. Bats are in belfries.
There's sure to be secret passageways
and places where they'd hide things.
Like that.
Yes .. I'm sure Miss Fiske has lots
of exciting things hidden in there.
Her jewels, I'm sure.
I've looked in all her boxes and
haven't been able to find them.
Are you both ready?
- Oh yes. Quite.
I managed to pack all
the lunch into one bag.
Mine.
Come here and sit down.
I want to talk to you both.
Now.
I haven't told you the real reason why
you're being sent away for a whole day.
The truth is I want to be entirely
alone with Miss Fiske for a few hours.
Is that why you got rid of Lucy too?
I didn't get rid of Lucy, Emily.
She had a toothache.
Oh Ellen dear, you know that's
not true. She didn't want to go at all.
I said she had a toothache, Louisa.
Now listen.
Last night, while you were both asleep,
I had a long talk with Miss Fiske.
She's tired of the marshes
and wants to travel for a bit.
I've persuaded her to
sell this house to me.
Not really, Ellen?
- We haven't discussed price yet.
That's why I must be alone with her, so
we can talk with nothing to distract us.
She may want more than
you're prepared to pay.
I'm prepared to pay
quite a big price, Emily.
Oh, lovely, lovely, lovely.
Oh Emily, aren't you excited?
- Louisa, be quiet.
Now, there's one more thing.
The most important.
You see this bible, both of you?
I want you to swear on it.
By father's memory.
That you'll never repeat a word of my
buying this house as long as you live.
What do I say?
Just say 'I swear'.
Oh .. I swear.
You too, Emily.
I won't swear on the bible. It's wicked.
If you don't Emily ..
I shan't buy the house and I'll
send you both back to London.
Oh Emily, be sensible.
I don't like being made
to do things .. I promise.
Now, remember.
That's a sacred oath.
Here's Bates. Hurry now.
There's no time to waste.
Drive slowly Bates.
Please don't let them get cold.
You can take your time. I shan't be
expecting you back before dusk.
Very good, ma'am.
Goodbye Ellen. I wish you could come.
- I wish you were coming too.
Goodbye Ellen.
- Goodbye.
Goodbye, dears.
Have a good time.
- Thank you.
I'm out of practice.
To dear Louisa and dear Emily.
May we never meet again.
That is so good.
[ Door knocks ]
May we come in?
- Yes.
I'd like to speak to Miss Ellen.
Unless Miss Fiske is back?
No, she's still away. I'll fetch Ellen.
We're making jam.
Good evening.
It isn't a very good one, is it?
No, as a matter of fact it's not.
Cats and dogs.
Good evening, Sisters.
Sorry to keep you waiting.
But we're in the middle of
putting up our quince jam.
Please don't apologise. I'm afraid
we've come on a begging errand.
Our supplier of oil hasn't
arrived from Rochester.
And the Reverend Mother wondered
if we might borrow a can until Sunday.
Of course .. Lucy.
Yes, Miss?
Will you run out to the shed
and bring in a can of paraffin.
Yes, Miss Ellen.
Won't you sit down, Sisters?
Hey. Shush ..
You again.
Bad pennies always turn up.
What are you doing here, hanging
about with the storm and all?
I've a little business inside.
Had to ensure the coast was clear.
What business?
- Listen, Lucky.
Is Miss Fiske about?
- No, she's away.
And my aunt Ellen?
- She's here right enough.
And them two crazy sisters of hers.
- Does she know I've been here before?
No. Mistress said not to say.
- Good. Get on with your work.
I'll come in the front door
like a proper gentleman.
Remember .. we don't know each other.
Not that we shan't .. later.
I'm very particular who I know.
For a moment, when I saw the candles
burning, I thought Miss Fiske was back.
Ellen's been lighting them lately.
She thinks Miss Fiske would like her to.
She says it keeps her memory burning.
When are you expecting her back?
I really couldn't say, Sister.
She hasn't written for over a fortnight.
We were so surprised
to learn she'd gone.
She hadn't mentioned she was
planning a journey anywhere.
No. It was quite unexpected.
She had a letter from some old
friends inviting her on a trip.
As they were sailing
the very next morning.
The Reverend Mother wonders
what to do about the rent.
From the little 3-acre field
we hire from Miss Fiske.
Well, I'm managing all her
affairs while she's away, Sister.
If you send it to me, I'll forward
it when I get her next address.
Here, Miss Ellen.
Good evening, Sisters.
- Thank you.
That seems heavy. Go with the
Sisters Lucy and give them a hand.
That's very kind of you, Miss Ellen.
- We've been bother enough.
I'll be glad to go. I'll get my cloak.
I think you are so brave
going out in the dark. I ..
I hate the dark .. it frightens me.
It shouldn't, my dear.
Don't you believe we're watched over?
Yes.
But I'm never quite sure
who is watching us.
I'm quite ready.
- We'd better be going.
Goodnight and thank you very much.
- Goodnight Sisters.
Goodnight.
There dear, you carry the oil.
And I'll hold the umbrella over us both.
Goodnight again.
- Goodnight.
Goodnight.
I must get back to the jam.
Ellen was unusually nice to
Sister Theresa, wasn't she.
They were quite chatty together.
- Louisa.
I think Ellen is changing.
I hope she's not getting
in league with the nuns.
Against us.
Ellen would never do that.
- She's taken to lighting those candles.
I think I'll blow them out.
- Ellen wouldn't like that.
Why should she have
everything her own way?
Emily.
What have you done?
- Something I wanted to do.
[ Door knocks ]
Louisa .. answer the door dear. Sister
Theresa's probably forgotten something.
[ Door knocks ]
Alright.
Don't be like that. I won't eat you.
Who are you?
And what do you want?
Dear aunt Ellen.
After all these years.
What a family reunion. I'm Albert.
Don't you remember me?
Albert.
Of course. Rose's boy.
- So it is.
Fancy Albert being here.
- Where on earth did you come from?
Gravesend .. on a duck's back.
It's Albert right enough.
Always saying funny things.
He's soaked through.
- Yes, so I see.
Don't stand there dripping
all over my best rug.
Go by the fire with your wet things.
That's more like my loving auntie.
My very distant auntie.
Now we'll have fun with Albert here.
I'll go and fetch him a dressing gown.
And I'll get him a towel.
So he can dry himself.
Blimey, if that don't half
make my mouth water.
Some nice, tasty grub and something
warm to chase it down the hatchway.
That's what I need.
Albert, tell me. Why have you come here?
That can wait until I'm dry outside.
And not so dry, in.
There you are, Albert.
Thanks, me old cup of tea.
Emily, slice off some beef,
and put out the bread and cheese.
A pint of half-and-half would
be the proper ticket with that.
This isn't a Tavern, Albert.
How about a spot of brandy to
take the damp out of my throat?
I'm unsure there's any
left in the decanter.
There's some in the cellar.
A cellar, eh? Your Ladyship,
allow me to lead you to it.
No .. I'll go myself.
Make way for the Duchess.
Blimey. The view from here
is the best on the marshes.
I say auntie, is this all yours?
- No, of course not.
It belongs to the woman
I work for. Miss Fiske.
Where is she, might I ask?
- Away.
Five years, auntie old girl.
- What of it?
You've changed.
- You've not.
The same big blue eyes though.
You're still Lady touch-me-not.
Let go of me. I'm in no
mood for your foolishness.
The way you seem to be all keyed up.
A little of my foolishness
just might do you no harm.
Here's your food, Albert.
Run up to bed, both of you.
I want to talk with Albert.
But we don't want to go to bed.
- No, we want to stay to talk to Albert.
Go on, do as aunt Ellen says. Toddle off
to bye-byes like good little girls.
Here, wait. Why don't you wet your
whistles. It will make you sleep tight.
Sleep tight. Albert, you are silly.
I don't think they'd better, Albert.
- What's the harm?
You don't have a long-lost
nephew every night of the week.
Fetch some glasses, Emily.
Very well, but not too much now.
- Just a tiny thimbleful for me, Albert.
How about you, aunt Ellen?
Nothing for me, thank you.
Now, my Siamese twins.
What about a toast, eh?
I don't know any.
In that case, here's to absent friends.
Absent friends.
Ellen, I suppose we
should think of Miss Fiske.
Who put out those candles?
- What candles?
Oh those.
- It must have been the wind.
Goodnight, Albert.
- Goodnight my lady.
- Goodnight.
It wasn't the wind, Ellen.
I say auntie, you've not
turned Roman have you?
I do this for a friend.
Now, Albert.
Let's stop all this 'auntie' nonsense
and get down to cases.
Why have you come here
and what do you want?
Well auntie .. I mean, Ellen.
To cut it fine, I'm taking a compulsory
holiday from my bank over in Gravesend.
In other words, you've lost your job.
- I've given it up.
You haven't done anything
wrong, have you?
I sort-of helped myself to a
little salary I wasn't entitled to.
You mean, you've stolen money.
This is rattling good brandy.
- Answer me, Albert.
You've got it.
- How much?
A small matter of a hundred pounds.
- I'll see.
I suppose you want me to give you the
hundred pounds so you can put it back?
I'm afraid it's too late for that.
They found out, the police.
The police?
A friend passed me the tip they were
coming. So I .. I took French leave.
But .. they'll follow you.
They'll come here.
Don't worry .. no-one knows I've got
relations out here on the marshes.
I'll be safe here for a lifetime.
You're certainly not going
to stay here for a lifetime.
Surely you don't mind me
staying for a while, do you?
Until it all blows over.
- Then what do you propose to do?
Clear out of the country.
America, Australia. Any old where.
I'm .. counting on you to help me.
I need money for my passage.
I'm .. I'm stony.
It won't cost much. Steerage.
I don't see why I should concern
myself with your affairs.
I'll land in prison if you don't.
You're not the sort to turn anybody down
who's in trouble and needed your help.
You wouldn't fail your
own flesh and blood.
I'm no flesh and blood of yours, Albert.
Won't you give me a
chance to start again?
I promise. Cross my heart.
I'll never do anything wrong
again for the rest of my natural.
Let me go.
Very well. I'll do it.
- Bless you, Ellen.
You're a daisy, you are.
- We'll talk about it in the morning.
You can sleep on the sofa tonight.
- I don't mind where I sleep.
But mind you ..
You can only stay until I've
arranged your passage on the boat.
Anything you say,
Ellen old girl .. what's that?
That's just the maid.
She's been out on an errand.
Lucy.
- Yes, Miss?
They'll be a gentleman
staying the night.
A gentleman staying?
A relation. He'll sleep in here.
Now go to your room and change your
wet clothes before you start sneezing.
Yes, Miss .. goodnight.
- Goodnight.
Goodnight.
'Lucy', is it?
Yes .. Lucy.
I fancy that's all for
tonight, aunt Ellen.
I'll just have a weed before
I turn in. The last of the day.
You seem to be taking this
all very lightly, Albert.
You have told me the worst, haven't you?
I mean, there isn't anything else?
- What else?
There are worse things than stealing.
For instance?
No, there's no blood on my hands.
Putting people out calls
for real nerve, you know.
Yes.
Goodnight, Albert.
- Nighty night.
Did you enjoy the sermon, Mr Bates?
Mighty powerful, Miss.
Yes. It was, wasn't it.
But there was a lot I didn't understand.
The part that went ..
How was it?
The wicked flee.
When no man .. pursueth.
But .. but ..
The righteous are as bold as a lion.
Well.
What do you think you're doing?
I fooled around with this padlock
last night and it .. came off.
You shouldn't have.
That's where Miss Fiske
keeps her valuables.
How does she get at them?
With a pickaxe? Look.
Well I never. All bricked up.
I wonder why that was done.
It wasn't that way the
last time I was here.
So you've had your nose
in there before, have you?
Funny what nasty thoughts
people have sometimes, isn't it.
Funny how they're right
sometimes, isn't it.
I wonder why anyone would want
to brick up a place like that?
Maybe Miss Fiske put her jewels
in there before she went away.
You know .. she's not one to take
any chances leaving them about.
Even with your aunt Ellen.
If there are any sparkles in there,
I wouldn't mind having a peep at them.
I'm sure you wouldn't.
- And neither would you, I dare say.
In fact .. I'm sure you'd like the feel
of some around your swan-like neck.
A pretty pink ear like
that calls for diamonds.
A wandering hand like yours
calls for a slap in the face.
It's wicked to slap a
man's face on a Sunday.
The better the day, the better the deed.
That leaves my conscience clear.
I'll scream.
What's that?
What do you think I'm made of?
- Sugar and spice.
And everything nice.
Blimey, you're strong.
It's a wig. Whose is it?
It is Miss Fiske's.
Oh, it's her best one.
She's as bald as a coot.
- Ah.
A wonder she didn't take it with her.
Hello.
Ah, she left a lot of
her fancy dresses too.
Perhaps she'll buy some
new ones up in London?
These are new. Most of them.
You'd better put that back up.
- Alright.
Get up on this chair.
You know, it is odd
she only took one wig.
On a trip, anything might happen.
A fire or a gust of wind.
Oh.
Here's Emily coming up the path.
You'd better be off.
Hello my old cup of tea.
What are you doing with those
bull-rushes? Looking for Moses?
You're making fun of me .. naughty boy.
Hello Ducky .. I'm glad you're
back before the others.
It isn't often I have the chance of
a tte--tte with the family's fairest.
You're never serious
about anything, Albert.
I was never more serious in my life.
The storm did an enormous
amount of damage.
Roads into Rochester and Gravesend
were completely flooded.
The Postman told me.
- I hope they stay that way.
Allow me, Empress.
There's only one letter today.
It's for Miss Fiske.
Is it?
It's a cosy nest you got here.
What's will happen to you
when Miss Fiske gets back?
Will she let you stay on, do you think?
She isn't coming back.
Why not?
Ellen's bought the house.
Go on.
Yes. It's quite true.
It's a secret though.
Ellen made us swear on the bible
that we wouldn't tell anyone.
But you are one of the family.
So it's alright.
Why should she want
to keep it a secret, eh?
I don't know.
It was done in a great hurry.
Louisa and I were sent off to Rochester.
Then when we came back that night,
Miss Fiske was gone and it was all over.
You won't tell Ellen I told
you, will you, Albert?
No.
We'll make that our
little secret, shall we?
Alright.
It will be rather fun.
Having a secret from Ellen.
She thinks she's the clever one.
But she isn't.
Not always.
No.
Albert.
- What?
Good morning.
May we come in?
Who's that?
- A couple of nuns from The Priory.
You talk to them, Albert.
I've got to tidy up the orchard.
Oh .. I didn't know there was
a young man staying here.
Is Miss Ellen about?
Sorry. She's gone over to the church at
Cawley. I'm her nephew, can I help?
We came to return this. She lent us
a little oil last night. We ran short.
Thanks.
- Yes, and this.
The rent for the little field.
Your aunt will understand.
I'll give it to her.
We are so looking forward
to Miss Fiske's return.
She's a dear friend of ours.
Oh .. have you .. heard from her lately?
No, not a word.
I think the Reverend Mother is
a trifle hurt she hasn't written.
In fact, she didn't even tell
us she was going away.
Not very chummy, was it.
- No, it wasn't.
Good morning.
- Good morning.
Now what are you up to?
- Fetch me a knife, Ducky.
What's that?
- A letter for Miss Fiske.
You're not going to open it?
- No. Wouldn't think of it.
What's it say?
'Dear Madam.
Regarding your instructions ..'
'To forward the amount of the
enclosed cheque in 5-pound notes'.
'Your signature appears to differ from
that with which we are acquainted'.
'We should be obliged if you
could kindly confirm same ..'
'By signing it afresh.
In your usual manner'.
Fifty pounds.
Notice the date.
'October 14th'.
That's three days ago.
She's been gone longer than that.
Since the beginning of September.
She probably made it
out from wherever she is.
Yes, she could have. Hey, wait a minute.
In that case, why did they
send the reply to her here?
You see who it's made payable to?
Ellen Creed.
What of it? I expect it's
the housekeeping money.
Maybe. Where's the glue-pot?
- Over there.
Get it for me.
Dip your finger in it.
- I should say not.
I've had no hand in this.
Haven't you?
You are a filthy pig.
- Go on. Seal it up.
Go on.
Don't forget.
You're in this as deep as me now.
I wish you'd never come here.
I don't know what comes over
me when you're around.
You won't give me away
to Ellen, will you?
I won't if you keep your mouth shut.
Here come the performing seals.
Not a word, mind you.
Albert.
Hello, aunts .. had a nice pray?
You should have been at church, Albert.
The minister told us all about Hell.
You'd have enjoyed the
bit about the lost souls ..
Sizzling in the bottomless pit.
Would I now? Sounds frightening.
Ellen .. where is Hell?
Hell is like the Kingdom of Heaven.
It is within.
That reminds me.
One of your religious friends was here.
She left you this.
It's the rent for some field or other.
She didn't see you, did she?
- I couldn't avoid it.
That was Sister Theresa.
She's Miss Fiske's friend. She doesn't
like us any more than Miss Fiske did.
Didn't Miss Fiske like you?
She was horrid to us.
Louisa, run upstairs
and change your dress.
You can't sit around
in your best all day.
No. I shan't, shall I.
No. Of course not.
Albert.
- Huh?
I don't want you to mention Miss Fiske
again in front of my sisters.
They quarrelled with her.
And it upsets them very
much to talk about her.
Sorry. Nobody told me.
What did you quarrel about?
I didn't say I quarrelled with her.
Would she by any chance be the friend
you lit those candles for last night?
Yes.
When did she die?
Die?
Who said anything about her being dead?
I just assumed she was.
You don't light candles for the living.
Do you?
- I don't know.
I just thought they stood for prayer.
I must find Emily.
- By the way.
The postman gave her
a letter for Miss Fiske.
From her bank, I believe.
Give it to me.
I'm managing all her
affairs while she's away.
Anything important?
- Yes, rather.
I must get an answer
in the post immediately.
A stylish looking piano you've got here.
Don't distract me, Albert.
I must concentrate.
I'm sorry. Don't mind me, auntie.
I say, you are up to date.
I didn't expect to find a copy of
The Mikado way out here on the marshes.
[ Whistling song: Tit-Willow ]
Don't do that.
I'm sorry. I didn't
mean to distract you.
It's just I happen to dislike that
particular tune. That's all.
It's a bit on the morbid side.
Miss Ellen, how soon
will you want dinner?
In a quarter of an hour, Lucy.
I'll just post this
letter at the crossing.
Let me go, Ellen.
I can do with a sniff of air.
No thank you.
I prefer to attend to this myself.
What are you up to now?
She just wrote a reply to
the letter we opened.
I thought it would be interesting
to see what she says.
'Dear sir'.
'Cheque'.
Something.
'Incorrect'.
'Owing'.
Something, something.
'Wrist'.
What does that word
look like to you? See.
'S .. p .. r ..'
S .. p .. r.
'Sprained'. That's it.
'Owing to a sprained wrist'.
Something. 'Yours'.
'Leonora'.
'Leonora Fiske'.
She signed it 'Leonora Fiske'.
What's it mean, Albert?
What do you think?
It looks as if she's pretending
to be Miss Fiske.
Getting money on the strength of it.
- Brilliant.
If that's true, she's a thief.
Like you.
- Shut up.
What will happen when
Miss Fiske comes back?
Suppose she isn't coming back?
Suppose she's died somewhere.
And Ellen is the only one who knows.
You can't die and only
one person know it.
Can't you? I'm not so sure.
One thing I do know.
She'd never risk it unless she knew
Miss Fiske was out of the way for good.
Alright .. assume she's dead.
Aunt Ellen is having the funds.
It might be years before
anybody would find out.
Why should she reap all the benefit?
There may be some pickings in it for us.
Would you like to see a bit of the
world? Have some fun with me?
You'd tempt Old Nick
himself, wouldn't you?
You've got to help me get proof.
I don't want to do anything
mean or underhanded.
Would I ask you to? Use your eyes
and keep your ears open. That's all.
What do you say?
I don't know.
Perhaps this will help
you make up your mind.
Well?
- I'll help you, Albert.
Here she comes. Look sharp now.
Back to the kitchen.
She's coming.
Blimey. You almost made
me frightened myself.
Hurry up, hurry up.
- Alright. Shut up.
Hey, go in the kitchen
and make some tea.
Take this with you. Go on, hurry.
Goodnight, Bates.
- Night, ma'am.
Don't forget.
Ten o'clock tomorrow morning.
Very good, ma'am.
Did you have a successful trip?
Yes.
I have your ticket.
You leave tomorrow.
Do I?
Where are my sisters?
- I sent them off to bed.
They were getting a little out of hand.
- I dare say it wasn't their fault.
Lucy is making some hot tea.
We thought you might be cold.
I'll be down again .. as soon as
I've said goodnight to them.
Is everything alright?
No it's not. She's packing me off
tomorrow. We've got to move fast.
You haven't changed your mind, have you?
- I couldn't refuse you anything .. now.
We thought you'd never come,
Ellen .. I was frightened.
Frightened?
Yes, they were such funny noises.
It was only the rats.
What have you been doing all evening?
We played a game of cribbage.
Of course, Albert cheated.
But it was rather fun
watching him cheat.
He hasn't said anything
about Miss Fiske?
No.
- Miss Fiske?
Why should he?
And neither of you spoke to him
about my buying the house?
No, Ellen.
Do you remember?
You made us swear on
the bible we wouldn't.
I think you'd better go to
sleep now, both of you.
I'm going downstairs to have a
hot cup of tea before I go to bed.
Albert, do you think ..?
- Pour the tea, Lucy.
Thank you Lucy. You may go to bed now.
- Yes, Miss Ellen.
Goodnight.
- Goodnight.
Auntie, where is your cane?
You look like you'd like to take down
my breeches and give me a dozen.
There's a boat sailing for Canada
on Friday. You sail with it.
I'm not sure I want to go to Canada.
Yet a while.
You haven't much choice, have you?
I don't know. I'm getting
quite fond of this place.
The air suits me .. I'm very
happy here for the time being.
I'm not happy having you here.
- Why?
It isn't safe since Sister Theresa
knows you're staying here with us.
The wrong sort of talk would bring
the police around here in no time.
I don't propose to risk a
scandal on your account.
There's more to it than that.
Lucy is apt to talk.
I don't think we need worry about her.
No. You've made sure of that.
Whatever do you mean by that?
- You know what, you cheap little ..
Stop it Ellen.
You'll make me lose my temper.
Your temper?
You leave first thing in the morning.
That's the end of you and your temper.
I shouldn't try to bluff me.
I'm not bluffing you. I order you.
- If I don't choose to be ordered?
I can't throw you out physically.
But I can send for the police.
And have your scandal?
Really, you're being very
inconsistent now, auntie dear.
You won't send for the police.
Why are you so sure?
Because you've another reason.
A more important reason for
not wanting the police here.
For wanting me out of this
house as quickly as possible.
As a matter of fact, you are right.
Now we get down to brass tacks.
Did it concern Miss Fiske by any chance?
It would and it does.
I met her in town today.
She's coming back.
She's coming back?
- And why shouldn't she?
I thought she'd gone for good.
How utterly absurd of you, Albert.
There has never been any
question of her not coming back.
Why didn't you say
so in the first place?
You played the fool so much
with Louisa and Emily.
I was afraid you'd blurt it out.
As it is, I'll have to
break it to them gently.
Because it means
they will have to go too.
My little country holiday has
obviously come to an end.
I don't know what the
blazes I'll do in Canada.
I suppose one can starve there
as well as anywhere else.
You'll get on.
I'll give you a little
something to start off with.
For your mother's sake.
I suppose I should extend
my most humble thanks.
No. That from you would be too much.
If that's all we have to say to each
other, I may as well get up to bed.
A good night's sleep wouldn't
do you any harm, either.
You look a bit played out.
I must lock up first.
Will I be seeing you in the
morning before I leave?
Yes.
I forgot to tell you, auntie.
I had a funny dream last night.
Did you?
I dreamt Miss Fiske was dead.
Goodnight, auntie.
- Goodnight, Albert.
Miss Fiske ..
Albert.
Albert!
Good morning, Bates.
Miss Creed ordered me. It's about the
train, but she didn't say which one.
Bates.
Cancel it. Miss Creed's
not feeling well.
Nothing serious I hope, sir?
No. Nothing serious.
In that case, I'd better hop along.
She did look ill when I
took in her early tea.
I wish we hadn't done it.
Pull yourself together.
You'll ruin everything. Go on upstairs.
She might have died.
- Shut up.
Well she didn't. And we
proved what we wanted.
Miss Fiske is dead and she knows it.
- I wonder when she died.
One more go, and I'll tell you when
and how, she died. Now, go on upstairs.
What did Bates want, Albert?
He brought the news from the outside
world. It will tickle you to death.
Wigs and whiskers are
coming back in again.
I don't think this is a
time for joking, Albert.
With Ellen the way she is.
You take this thing too seriously,
my old brussels sprout.
She was walking in her sleep
and had a nightmare. That's all.
It wasn't a nightmare, Albert.
Oh .. what was it then?
- She says she saw a ghost.
In that case, lay another
place for breakfast.
Do you really think
it was a ghost, Emily?
If it were only a nightmare,
we wouldn't have heard it too.
Heard what?
- The music. Miss Fiske's music.
You know, Emily.
I'm sometimes afraid Miss Fiske
will get the better of Ellen.
I sometimes think she wants
to come back and turn us out.
I think Miss Fiske is here .. now.
Well .. what are you
two whispering about?
Hadn't you better go for your walk now?
- Yes, Ellen.
Anything you say, Ellen.
Do you think you're
strong enough to be up?
Yes, dear. I'm quite alright now.
- Hadn't you better have a doctor?
No. A doctor couldn't do any good.
Why are you two standing
there like a couple of owls?
Emily has been frightening me.
You've been imagining
things, both of you.
Now, run along for your walk.
Whatever you say, Ellen. You know best.
Good morning, aunt Ellen.
We didn't expect you down today.
Why aren't you ready yet?
Bates will be here at any moment.
Bates has been here and
gone .. I sent him away.
What do you mean by interfering
with my arrangements?
I didn't like to go and leave
you not feeling well.
I'm quite recovered now, thank you.
It was a queer turn you had last night.
What happened?
Nothing.
You know, you should really do
something about your nerves.
This isn't the first time you've walked
in your sleep, according to Emily.
What's Emily told you?
Just the usual chatter.
They do say that people who walk in
their sleep have a guilty conscience.
What's behind that remark, Albert?
Nothing.
You know.
Uhuh.
Then it was you last night?
- Yes.
Me and Lucy.
- She knows too?
Not what I know. That's something you
and I are going to keep to ourselves.
Provided of course, you treat me right.
What are you going to do?
As I said, I'm very happy here.
I think with your financial help I'll
be able to adjust things at the bank.
And we can all settle down in peace.
A contented little family.
You mean, you propose
to go on living here?
With me?
- Why not?
You'd never be quite sure, would you?
You might not enjoy your meals.
You wouldn't dare .. a second time.
It takes a lot of courage to
kill for the first time, Albert.
Once you've sold your soul to
the Devil it becomes easier.
Much easier.
Alright .. give me 500 and I'll clear
out for good. And keep my mouth shut.
I'm not afraid of you, Albert.
And your shabby little tricks.
In the middle of the night, you may
fancy yourself cutting quite a figure.
It's broad daylight now.
[ Door knocks ]
It's those nuns.
Get that out of sight.
And yourself with it.
[ Door knocks ]
Good day, Sisters.
- I must talk to you, right away.
Are you alone?
- Yes.
What's the matter?
It's really none of my business
and I shouldn't have come but ..
The police. They've been to the Priory.
- What about?
They're searching for a young man.
Who stole money from a
bank over Gravesend way.
And from the description,
I suspect it was your nephew.
I thought if he were told, he might
have a chance to do the right thing.
And give himself up.
It is your nephew?
- Yes.
But they mustn't search here.
- They've gone to the Coyne farm first.
I heard one of them say so.
Oh Miss Ellen. Have I done
wrong in coming to warn you?
I don't know, Sister.
I had a brother rather like that.
He went wrong too.
People are so easily lost, aren't they?
Yes they are.
Poor girl. You have so many burdens.
If you refer to Albert.
He means absolutely nothing to me.
No-one does, for that matter.
Except Emily and Louisa.
If, any time, we can do anything to make
things easier for you or your sisters ..
Don't hesitate to turn to us.
That's very kind of you, Sister Theresa.
But you know, we're not of your faith.
In my Father's house are many mansions.
Blimey, I thought they'd never go.
Thanks for putting in
a good word for me.
The Coyne farm, is it?
That will give me a chance to
get behind them to the river.
Hurry. There's no time to lose.
- Yes, I'll get my clothes.
Lucy.
Why are you staring at me like that?
You've been listening.
Lucy.
Lucy, come back.
What's up?
What is it?
Lucy's run off.
She was listening.
Turn me in, would she?
I've got to move fast.
Where's that money and boat ticket?
You mean, she heard all about that?
Yes.
Hey .. you'd better
make a dash for it too.
Don't stand there mooning about.
Put your things on and
let's get out of here.
I'm not going.
Are you out of your mind?
You know what they'll do to you?
- You'd better hurry, Albert.
Well, if that don't beat the cards.
Well then ..
So long Ellen .. no hard feelings.
Ellen, it was so funny.
We just saw Albert.
He was playing 'tag' with some men.
He didn't win. They caught him.
He got quite annoyed.
Ellen, look.
We found a lot of jackdaw feathers.
We're going to tie them into
bundles and make little dusters.
Where are you going?
I'm going to Coyne farm.
There are some gentlemen there from
Gravesend and I want to see them.
You won't bring them
back here, will you Ellen.
It's so nice and peaceful by ourselves.
No, dear. I'll try not to
bring them back here.
You have been happy here, haven't you?
- We are happy here, aren't we Emily?
Yes .. it's much better than London.
It's so good of you to have
bought this house for us.
You have been clever, Ellen.
How long will you be?
I don't know, dear.
Maybe quite a time.
I think I shall go down
to The Priory tomorrow.
I should like to see the things the
Reverend Mother collected on the marsh.
I'll go with you.
Goodbye, Ellen .. don't worry about us.
We can look after ourselves.
..t-g..